las fuertes precipitaciones afectaron
también a la capital venezolana este
lunes en el barrio 23 de enero uno de
los más emblemáticos ubicados en el
oeste de Caracas las autoridades
tuvieron que desalojar al menos 42
familias luego de que varias viviendas
colapsaran y afectarán a más de 100
personas en los altos mirardinos se
registraron desbordamiento de quebradas
que afectaron no solo viviendas sino
también arrasaron múltiples vehículos
sin duda uno de los estados más
afectados ha sido el estado aragua este
lunes Se confirmó que ascendió a 4 el
número de fallecidos tras el
desbordamiento del río castaño que
recordemos la semana pasada afectó esta
zona y el pasado 8 de octubre también en
el estado aragua en tejerías
Lamentablemente 54 personas fallecieron
tras el desbordamiento de cinco
quebradas otro de los estados bastante
afectados ha sido Mérida el gobernador
reportó que al menos 60.000 familias Aún
se encuentran sin acceso a agua potable
pues varios diques colapsaron también
por las Fuertes lluvias el pronóstico no
es el Instituto Nacional de meteorología
prevé lluvias en las próximas horas y en
los próximos días producto del paso de
las ondas tropicales